I was into that Girls Club the TV show
so I thought like all the especially
girls gonna be like super aggressive
my grandparents right they're like in
their estonia's right now when I told
them that I was moving out here like my
grandma almost had a heart attack just
like no don't go this is a huge mistake
tell you how my mom summarizes a United
States my mom says you guys are dressed
horrible your guys eat terrible exempt
aureus do you think that Americans are
also pretty loud you have this mentality
and this way of being of being very loud
and out there and thinking you're the
best people really value their opinions
not to say that in Kenya we don't allow
your opinions but perhaps it comes from
the mindset where I traveled to the US
as an individual maybe because I'm a
minority I feel like I'm representing
Kenya in this case so I am opinionated
but also very aware that when I say
certain things it can reflect on my
culture before coming to the u.s. and my
expectations were this was gonna be the
land of opportunity and I was gonna get
a job right away the movies and TV shows
you know that we watch on in Singapore
paints like a super nice picture of
America personally growing up I always
thought that America was like this
dreamland was like watching all this
movies and I was like Americans are like
way too cool like I don't know if I can
like go there
Americans are doing this cool because
they come from a country which has all
the resources they need I'm never here
I do love it I just feel relaxed even my
brother and this
in China when he visited me injustice I
said if just feel relaxed when I came
here I didn't know English by like
people are like so nice and people
everyone like to try to understand what
I'm trying to say and then a lot of
people help me too my mom was like she
really supported me the idea of me
moving out here to study and everything
but then my dad was like a little bit
like I don't know like I'm not against
it but I feel like Americans are like
much more materialistic but then he came
out here and to like visit me he was
like okay I actually kind of liked it
you're like people here are super nice
and welcoming Americans are very
friendly you know generally Singaporeans
actually do think Americans are friendly
in my country like LGBT people still I
cannot be open I think you're not but
here is everyone is open I get one can
be different and then LGBT that's
beautiful and I love that you know just
like in you you freak I'm always saying
I'm in United States one thing you just
came by it the freedom the freedom and
you want to speak the freedom one that
you do things you want to sleep on the
couch 24 hours and nobody cares
no social service or knock on door so
you shouldn't get up to go to work or
you can't work a 24-hour nobody's
stopping you - so that's the freedom the
choice I think that's the bigger
difference I feel like a lot of people
my age they realize more that it's this
tension between our countries Russia and
America largely because of the media and
the
younger people are like oh like we get
it it's cool like we're cool with Russia
and like other countries it's just the
government it's not the people Oh
sometimes when we watch the news and we
see specific incidences that occur in
the country that are perhaps negative to
different types of people that's when we
kind of see and I said wait a minute
like every country has its issues
because all we ever see is the good side
of everything and I think that's when it
kind of gets to a point where we see
we're kind of all together in the same
boat despite being a first world country
and having a developing country we're
all dealing with different issues in our
country
[Music]